ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERONE
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. DEGREE ARE
CURRY. ARAMBULA BARRICADE HAND
BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW. BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BURKE
CALDERON CORREO CERVANTES CHAU
CHEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
APRIL GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GONZALEZ
GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA. KILEY LACKEY LEAD
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL THIS IN PETRIE-NORRIS
QUIRK QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RAY IS
LOOSE REBAJAS ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO%
SAY ARTURO SMITH. STONE T.
BALLOT AREAS THE APPROVED VIA
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WICKS WORD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER THE
DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM YES
YOUR CON YOU MA'AM IS THERE. IN
THE NAME OF GOD. THE MOST
GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL. HOW
MANY GUARD. EVERYTHING STARTS
FROM PRAYER. WITHOUT ASKING YOU
FOR LOVE. WE CAN NOT POSSESS
LOVE. AND STILL LESS ARE WE
ABLE TO GIVE IT TO OTHERS. WE
MAY BE EXHAUSTED WITH THE WORK.
BUT UNLESS OUR WORK IS
INTERWOVEN WITH LOVE. IT IS
USELESS HELP US TO LOVE MORE
COMPLETELY ALL GUARD THIS DAY
AND ALWAYS ARMENIAN. THANK YOUR
MOM YOUR FEAR WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE. COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN
ME IN SALUTING OUR FLAG I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. HELLO YEAH.
ONE HUNDRED. INDIVISIBLE
LIBERTY AND ALL THANK YOU YOU
MAY BE SEATED. THREE OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
GERMAN SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY
MARKS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
MISTER FLORES FOR THE READING
F THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS IMPLICATIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. TODAY'S ABSENCES
FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS PETRIE-NORRIS IN WAX.
FOR ILLNESS IN THE FAMILY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN. MITHRAS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR MOTIONS
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE. TO ALLOW
SOMEONE MEMBERS BONTA RAMOS
IMPAIR QUE HAN TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT. TO RE REFER
TO THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY EIGHT
CHILD FROM TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE TO PUBLIC SAFETY. AB
THREE EIGHTY ONE DAVIES FROM
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TOO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. AB
TEN AWAIT TO GRAYSON FROM THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE TO LABOR
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE AND THEN
BACK TO INSURANCE COMMITTEE.
AND AB ELEVEN FORTY THREE
BERMAN FROM THE HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
TO THE JUST JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO REMOVE ITEMS FORTY
AND FORTY ONE EIGHTY FOUR
SEVENTY THREE CHAO AN EIGHTY
FOUR SEVENTY FOUR CHAU FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. AND REFERRED
THE BILLS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SEVEN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. MOVING TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE SECOND READING
FILE ITEMS ONE THROUGH TWENTY
ONE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FORTY ONE
FOUR NINETEEN TWENTY ONE WITH A
MINUTE SIXTY SIX OF THE
MINISTRY SIXTY SEVEN WITH A
MEMBERS FIVE SIXTY THREE WITH A
MEMBERS TEN EIGHTY SIX FOR THE
MINUTES THE REAL TO THEMINISTRY THIRTY SIX MINUTES SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN WITH A MINUTES.
SEVEN TWENTY SIX OF THE MEMBERS
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SIX WOMEN IT'S
A NINETEEN WITH A MEMBERS
TWELVE A ONE WITH A MINUTES
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX OF THE
MEMBERS FIVE FIFTY TWO WITH A
MEMBERS TWENTY SEVEN WITH IMAGE
THREE OF SIXTY MINUTES. A FIFTY
SIX OF THE MEMBERS FIVE FORTY
FOR THE MINUTES AND ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE TWENTY SIX MINUTES ALL
BILLS. WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. HAVING TO
THE THIRD READING FIVE. FILE
ITEM TWENTY TWO EIGHTY FIVE
FIFTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FIFTY SIX BY
SOME REMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AN
ACT RELATING TO CIVIL LAW. MR
MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THE MATTER. THANK YOU MISTER%
SPEAKER MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS FERTILITY FRAUD OCCURS
WHEN A DOCTOR THAT SPECIALIZES
IN ASSISTED REPRODUCTIVE
MEDICINE KNOWINGLY IMPLANTS A
PATIENT WITH A SPERM SAMPLE
THAT IS NOT THE ONE SELECTED
FROM THE DONOR BANK BUT IS
INSTEAD IS FROM THE DOCTOR HIM
OR HER HIMSELF. AB FIVE FIVE
SIX FOCUSES ON THE FINANCIAL
IMPACT THAT FERTILITY FRAUD HAS
ON VICTIMS CHOOSING TO UTILIZE
AND UNDERGO ASSISTIVE
REPRODUCTIVE MEDICINE IS A
COSTLY EXPENSE WITH SOME
TREATMENTS AND PROCEDURES BEING
EXPENSIVE. VICTIMS OFTEN SUFFER
FINANCIALLY AS SOME PARENTS USE
THEIR ENTIRE SAVINGS TO
CONCEIVE A FAMILY FOR ASSISTED
REPRODUCTIVE MEDICINE. FOR
CHOOSING TO UNDERGO THIS IS A
MONUMENTAL DECISION FOR PARENTS
AND BEING VICTIMIZED DURING THE
PROCESS CAN HAVE LONG LASTING
EFFECTS. PLEASE CONTINUE WITH
REFINANCE LANA MOSTLY AB FIVE
FIVE SIX WOULD PROVIDE A NEW
VENUE FOR VICTIMS OF FERTILITY
FRAUD TO PURSUE JUSTICE BY
SEEKING DAMAGES IN CALIFORNIA
COURTS. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN. YEAH SIX BEING IN
HEARING FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER FOR ME TRYING TO DO LIKE
THOSE. HE MADE A SPEECH I
REQUEST A AND I HAVE A THE YOU
BURKE WILL OPEN ROLE. MEMBERS.
VERY VOTE. ON MEMBERS VOTED OUT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF THE ARE
VOTE. PALMER GO TO THEIR TO
VOTE. BURKE CLOSE ROLE IN
TELUGU I SIXTY FOR NODE THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL PASS
AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEM TWENTY
THREE MOVING THE FILE ITEM
TWENTY FOUR AB NINE HUNDRED THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RADIUS AN ACT RELATING TO
TRUSTS. MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE A
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO THE
MAJORITY LEADER MITCH REYES YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER NUMBERS. TODAY I
PRESENT TO YOU AB NINE HUNDRED
TECHNICAL BILL THAT SIMPLY
FIXES AN INCONSISTENCY IN
CURRENT LAW AND ENSURES A
TRUSTEES. ARE ACTING IN GOOD
FAITH. AB NINE HUNDRED WOULD
REQUIRE CHARITABLE TRUSTEES TO
PROVIDE NOTICE TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WHAT THE CHARITABLE
TRUST INTENDS TO MOVE
SUBSTANTIALLY ALL CHARITABLE
ASSETS OWNED BY THE TRUST UNDER
EXISTING LAWS NONPROFIT PUBLIC
BENEFIT CORPORATIONS. ARE
REQUIRED TO GIVE WRITTEN NOTICE
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WHEN
THE OPERATION INTENDS TO MOVE
SUBSTANTIALLY ALL OF ITS ASSETS
HOWEVER DUE TO AN EXISTING
INCONSISTENCY WITHIN CALIFORNIA
TERRIBLE LOSS. CHARITABLE TRUST
HAVE BEEN ALLOWED TO
CIRCUMNAVIGATE THE SIMPLE
NOTICE THAT ALL NONPROFIT
CORPORATIONS ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
RAYOS SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
VERITABLE ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. HOW LONG MEMBERS
VOTED THERE TO VOTE. ON NUMBER
THIRTY TO THIRTY VOTE. THE
THIRD WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES AND FIFTY THREE
KNOWS FOURTEEN THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE WILL PASS. AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS TWENTY
FIVE THROUGH. THIRTY TWO.
IMAGINE LIVING TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY THREE AJ ARE FOR THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSUME JOINT
RESOLUTION FOR VICE AND WE
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE BASE OF
CONVENTION. MEMBERS. GARCIA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
RESOLUTION THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS EVEREST RIGHT
2% H. R. FORM AGER FOR CALLS
FOR THE UNITED STATES
RATIFICATION OF THE BASSEL
AGREEMENT A CRITICAL STEP
IMPROPERLY REGULATING
INTERNATIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL
INJUSTICE A PLASTIC DUMPING ON
DEVELOPING COUNTRIES THE VALVE
THE CONVENTION RESOLUTION ON
THE CONTROL OF THE TRANS
BOUNDARY MOVEMENT OF HAZARDOUS
WASTES AND THEIR DISPOSAL IS
FINE BUT NEVER RATIFIED BY THE
UNITED STATES WE'RE THE ONLY
DEVELOPED COUNTRY THAT HAS NOT
SAYING THIS RATIFICATION OUT
THERE WE'VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT
OUR PLASTIC PROBLEM OUT THERE
AND WE REALLY DO NEEDTO HAVE A
GLOBAL EFFORT- WORKING WITH
THEIR COUNTERPARTS ACROSS. THE
WORLD AT IN THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE BEST A CONVENTION
WAS AMENDED TO INCLUDE A MIX-
AND CONTAMINATED PLASTIC WASTE
SHIPMENTS WITHIN ITS CONTROL
PROCEDURES TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM OF THE PLASTICS WHAT
THIS MEANS IS THAT STARTING
THIS YEAR SUCH EXPERTS ARE
REQUIRED THE NOTIFICATION OF
CONSENT RECEIVING COUNTRIES
PRIOR TO EXPORT BUT BECAUSE THE
VESSEL- THE UNITED STATES IS
NOT PART OF THE BATTLE
CONVENTION WE CANNOT LEGALLY
EXPORT ANYWAYS MEANING THAT
ANYWAYS REPORTING IS CRIMINAL
ILLEGAL- AND CAN LEAD TO
LAWSUITS AND REYES REPARATION
EVENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON AND ENCOURAGING
THE VETERAN ADMINISTRATION TO
ACT IMMEDIATELY. TO RATIFY THE
VITAL CONVENTION. THANK YOU
MATH GARCIA. THE AND HEARING
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE RED. THIS
GARCIA WOULD YOU LIKE THE FIRST
OPEN PROVIDERS THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE FOR CO AUTHORS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THEIR TO VOTE
THIS IS HER CO AUTHORS. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED THIRD OF IT THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRED OF IT THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. YEAH CORRECT
WELL CLOSER AND TELL YOU THERE
FIVE CO AUTHORS ARE THE
RESOLUTE THE ROLE THEY'LL BE
OPEN FOR A VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED THERE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE AND I FIFTY SEVEN NEWS
HERE LUCIEN IS ADOPTED. WILL
PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEM.
THIRTY FOUR. WE'RE GOING TO
PASS THE RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS
THIRTY FOUR AND THIRTY FIVE.
MEMBERS. WE ARE MOVING TO A
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDARS
FILE ITEMS FORTY TWO THROUGH
FORTY SIX DOES ANY MEMBER WISH
TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING AND
HEARING THEN THE CLERK WILL
READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
SILVA AN ACT RELATING TO
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION. THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR OWN THEY
CAN THANK. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IN
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF. BURKE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE. BURKE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SEVENTY ONE KNOWS ZERO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
CLERK WILL READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SOME BILLS SIX THIRTY THREE
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SUM AGO A
NINETY ONE SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
SUM OF- NINE THIRTY EIGHT
SEVENTY ONE IS THE SYMBOL FOR
NINETY SIX HI. SEVENTY ONE ZERO
ZERO. IN THE ABSENCE OF A JACK
WE WILL MOVE THE PRE. ANNOUNCED
QUORUM CALL WILL BE LIFTED.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS QUORUM CALL
HAS BEEN LIFTED WE ARE MOVING
TO THE PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
INTERNMENT IN MEMORY I ASK THAT
YOU TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
BEGIN ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY I
ASK THAT YOU PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU MEMBERS. THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
ANY GERMAN IN MEMORY. MISTER
ROBERTS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER- I
REQUEST WE RISE TODAY WITH THE
ADJOURNMENT MEMORY OF JANET
LEAKING. YESTERDAY WOULD HAVE
BEEN HER SIXTY FOURTH BIRTHDAY
MISS KING WAS AN ENROLLED
MEMBER OF THE LUMBEE TRIBE IN
NORTH CAROLINA AND PASSED AWAY
IN OAKLAND THIS PAST FEBRUARY.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER DAUGHTER
CORALIE GARCIA MISS KING IS
REMEMBERED AS AN ANTI TO
COUNTLESS PEOPLE FAMILY AND
FRIENDS THEY KNEW HER AS A
HEALER. ADJUSTERS WORKER AND A
TEACHER. SHE DEVOTED HER LIFE
TO FAMILY AND FRIENDS BUT ALSO
TO THE NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY AS A WHOLE. HER
PROFESSIONAL CAREER CENTERED ON
POLICY ADVOCACY MENTAL HEALTH
ESPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH FOR
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITIES AND
NATIVE CHILDREN NATIVE
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS MENTAL HEALTH
IN GENERAL CHILD WELFARE. THE
FOLLOWING INSTITUTIONS WERE
FORTUNATE TO BENEFIT FROM HER
EFFORTS AND HER GENEROUS
SPIRIT. THE INTERTRIBAL
FRIENDSHIP HOUSE IN THE NATIVE
AMERICAN HEALTH CENTER THE SAN
FRANCISCO AMERICAN INDIANS
CENTER THE AMERICAN INDIAN
CHILD RESOURCE CENTER. THE
HIMSELF CUCKOOS WHOSE HOUSE OF
CHILDREN CHILD DEVELOPMENT
CENTER IN OAKLAND. ERICA THE
INDIAN FAMILY HEALING CENTRE IN
OAKLAND A SUBSTANCE USE
TREATMENT CENTER FOR NATIVE
WOMEN AND THEIR CHILDREN AND
THE CENTER FOR AMERICAN INDIAN
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION AND- WE
EXTEND OUR CONDOLENCES TO HER
DAUGHTER HER FRIENDS AND. IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA TO
WHICH SHE DEDICATED HER LIVE
HER LIFE THIS IS SOMEONE THAT
HAS GIVEN BACK TO THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I ASK.
THAT WE ADJOURNED IN HER
MEMORY- THANK YOU MISTER RAMOS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR CHAMBER
BEER GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I TO
RISE TO JOIN IN MEMORY OF JANET
LEIGH KING YESTERDAY WOULD HAVE
BEEN HER SIXTY FOURTH BIRTHDAY.
SHE FIRST CAME TO THE BAY AREA
IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES SHE
CAME FROM THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY WHERE SHE WAS RAISED SHE
SETTLED IN OAKLAND. WHERE FOR
MORE THAN FORTY YEARS HE WAS A
GENTLE BUT A POWERFUL VOICE FOR
THE NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY
SHE WAS DEDICATED TO SUPPORTING
NATIVE COMMUNITY WELLNESS.
AMONG MANY OTHER ISSUES SHE
FIRST BEGAN WORKING AT
OAKLAND'S INTERTRIBAL
FRIENDSHIP HOUSE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE. AND SHE WORKED IN
SEVERAL DIFFERENT CAPACITIES
THROUGHOUT HER LIFETIME SHE
ALSO WORKED AT THE AMERICAN
INDIAN CHILD RESOURCE CENTER
ALSO IN OAKLAND WHERE SHE WAS A
FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR NATIVE.
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES SHE WAS A
FIRM BELIEVER THAT EACH
GENERATION HAS THE DUTY TO ON
LEARNING ITS OWN INTERNALIZED
COLONIZATION. THE TWO
ORGANIZATIONS I MENTIONED WERE
ESPECIALLY CLOSE TO HER HEART
AND IT'S ATESTAMENT TO HER
COMMUNITY WORK AND LEGACY THAT
WHEN SHE PASSED MORE THAN
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS WAS
DONATED IN HER MEMORY. TO
BENEFIT INTERTRIBAL FRIENDSHIP
HOUSE AND AMERICAN INDIAN CHILD
RESOURCE CENTER. MISTER SPEAKER
I ASK THAT THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF
JANET LEIGH CAME. THANK YOU MR
BONTA IS A MEMBER OF OUR CAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY
TO JOIN IN THE MEMORY OF DUBLIN
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD
TRUSTEE CATHERINE QUACH. WHO
TRAGICALLY DIED AFTER
SUSTAINING FATAL WOUNDS IN AN
ACCIDENT ON MARCH TWENTY
FOURTH. SHE WAS VOLUNTEERING TO
HAND OUT FOOD FOR THE FARMERS
TO FAMILIES PROGRAM I FELT
FALLON MIDDLE SCHOOL WHEN THE
ACCIDENT OCCURRED SHE DIED AS
SHE LIVED SERVING OUR COMMUNITY.
SHE LIVED WITH HER HUSBAND
WILLIAM HER SON THOMAS AND HER
DAUGHTER NATALIE IN DUBLIN
CALIFORNIA. THEY'VE CALLED
DUBLIN HOME SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY NINE. AND ARE DEEP AND
MEANINGFUL PART OF THE
COMMUNITY AND CATHERINE WILL BE
VERY MUCH MISSED. CATHERINE WAS
BORN TO A FAMILY OF IMMIGRANT
PARENTS FROM SOUTH KOREA IN
REDWOOD CITY SHE GREW UP IN
SARATOGA AND STUDY PSYCHOLOGY
AT UCLA WHERE SHE MET HER
HUSBAND WILLIAM. RATIONALLY SHE
WORKS IN HR AND RECRUITING
BUSINESS ANALYSIS AND RETAIL
PLANNING MANAGEMENT. SEVERAL
YEARS AGO KATHERINE WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER AND SHE
DEFIED THE ODDS TO. TO RECOVER
FROM THE DISEASE AND CONTINUE
TO LIVE A FULL AND MEANINGFUL
LIFE. HER FAMILY SAID SHE WAS
KNOWN FOR BEING THE LIFE OF THE
PARTY THE NEIGHBORHOOD THE
COMMUNITY AND THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN CAMPAIGNING
TIRELESSLY FOR THE CAUSES OF
THE UNDERSERVED FORGOTTEN AND I
PRESSED HER HUSBAND WILLIAM
SAID SHE TAUGHT ME TO LOVE MY
KIDS MORALLY AND
UNCONDITIONALLY SHE WAS THE
OPTIMIST THE GLASS HALF FULL
CHEERFUL AND ACCEPTING SHE HAD
A CLEAR SENSE OF WHAT WAS RIGHT
AND WRONG SHE WAS OUR MORAL
COMPASS. CATHERINE WAS ELECTED
TO REPRESENT AREA THREE AND THE
DUBLIN UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN A SPECIAL ELECTION IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN AND
WAS REELECTED TO A FULL TERM IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY SHE WAS
AN ACTIVE VOLUNTEER IN THE
COMMUNITY DEDICATED TO THE WELL
BEING OF FAMILIES INCLUDING HER
OWN. I HAD THE PLEASURE OF
WORKING WITH KATHERINE DURING
HER TENURE ON THE SCHOOL BOARD
I WAS ALWAYS STRUCK BY HER
PASSION FOR THE CHILDREN FOR
DISTRICT AND HER KEEN
UNDERSTANDING OF THE ISSUES
THEY FACED OUR STATE MY
DISTRICT AND THE DUBLIN
COMMUNITY SUFFERED A MAJOR LOSS
WITH CATHERINE'S PASSING.
KATHERINE'S LOVE FOR FAMILY HER
LIFE OF SERVICE WAS CUT MUCH
TOO SHORT. MAY HER MEMORY
FOREVER BE A BLESSING THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. THANK YOU
MISTER CAN. MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES OF THE DOES TO
BE PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUEST TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINT
IN THE JOURNAL. MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULES AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
APRIL SIXTH CHECK IN SESSION.
WEDNESDAY APRIL SEVENTH SECOND
SESSION THURSDAY APRIL EIGHTH
FLOOR SESSION AT NINE AM. ALL
OF THE- ITEMS THE REMAINING
WILL BE PASSED RETAIN ALL OCEAN
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS
SUMMARY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN. SIMILAR BONTA
MOTIONS AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS OF THIS HOUSE IN A
JOURNEY UNTIL THURSDAY APRIL
EIGHTH AT NINE AM.